this is a production of Cornell
University all right hi everyone thank
you for staying to the very end
hopefully I can entertain you with the
final frontier the clavo bacter solanum
path the system so this is and this talk
I'll give you a snippet of some of my
dissertation research that has been
unfolding over the past year and I'm
currently a fourth-year PhD graduate
student in Chris Mars lab up in Geneva
so bacterial canker of tomato is caused
by a gram positive pathogen called klava
bacter michigan and sis subspecies
Michigan Ensis so this is a seaborne
bacterial pathogen that can spread in
these greenhouse production facilities
like I'm showing through water dispersal
through mechanical inoculation and can
cause a lot of problems for growers
across New York State and across the
world so once this bacterium is inside
of the plant it spreads through the
vascular system colonizing the xylem
tissue and in later stages of infection
induces these stem cankers that you see
up there and as well as causing
unilateral wealth and marginal leaf
necrosis during kind of later stages of
infection as well on the fruit you can
form a can form these bird's eye lesions
that can reduce the quality of the fruit
and also lead to economic loss so this
pathogen is especially important in New
York because we're the number five
producer of tomatoes in the USA and a
lot of these Tomatoes go to fresh
markets so they need to be blemish free
it can't have these lesions and so some
of the work we're trying to do is to
support this industry in New York
importantly there is no currently no
known qualitative resistance to this
pathogen so we I was interested in
understanding tolerance to this
bacterial pathogen and we started by
looking through the literature and
finding that there were published
tolerant accessions of solanum fabric
IDs and Solanum Arcanum and I began
screening them with both wild-type and
also a hyper virulent mutinous clavo
vector and what you can see here is I
won't be able to see that is the most
acceptable so let's solanum lycopersicum
cultivar mountain fresh and also our
most tolerant accession Solanum Arcanum
two and five seven and what we found is
that the bacteria
able to colonize the tolerant accession
to a pretty high density albeit less
than in the most susceptible plant and
but it is impeded in its ability to
spread through the vascular system
vertically along with looking at kind of
the vascular stage of this of this
disease we're screening these fruit to
see if they're tolerant to the fruit
portion of the infection and so
currently we have a lot of data for two
of the four accessions us and including
the susceptible solanum lycopersicum and
also Solanum Arcanum two and seven too
different from the one I showed you
before and what we can see is that these
bird's eye lesions form on all of the
all of the genotypes and it's
interesting because anything this slide
I showed you before it was completely
asymptomatic and the vascular stage
however it is able to form lesions on
the fruit in that asymptomatic species
so this has led us to some interesting
hypotheses and directions where I'm
taking this work that I won't be able to
show you all the pictures I have but
we're looking at the the host vascular
morphology and how that impacts the
ability for CMM to spread between xylem
vessels and also vertically so we're
using a mix of confocal microscopy as
well as scanning electron microscopy to
see the colonization patterns of the
bacteria and kind of focus in on
individual xylem vessels and see how the
bacteria are able to aggregate within
those we're also interested in looking
at how the bacterium alters the host
xylem eco kind of system environmental
system whatever and we're using SAP
metabolomics to try to understand that
both in the tolerant and the susceptible
species so that work will be coming
within the next year so with that I'd
like to acknowledge my lab and everyone
that has participated in this project
and helped out a lot and Mary Jean well
sir help me with the SEM and I didn't
put up there but I'd also like to take
thank the RIC tomato genetics research
center and also USDA grant in Geneva for
providing tomato germ plasm I think we
have a couple seconds for questions and
thank you
yes yes
so the hyper virulent strain of cloud
factors so that's a knockout of an
expansion like gene from the bacterium
so it's a secreted expansion protein or
expansive like protein that still the
molecular mechanism that is still
unknown
all right thank you
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu